Les voitures normales prennent
de la valeur content tenu de la
rareté.
Jérôme Bergeron.
- La famille Jean-Pierre
est à la recherche d'un véhicule
d'occasion, et ça presse.
- Ma voiture, bien, celle qu
Problème de transmission,
l'auto était quand même
assez âgée, donc ça valait pas
la peine de mettre l'argent
dessus.
vers cette Toyota Corrola 2013
à fort prix dans les
circonstances, puisqu'il est
presque impossible de repartir
avec les clés d'une voiture
neuve chez un conc
- L'auto m'était destinée!
- Les voitures d'occasion
chauds, ce qui crée
une véritable frénésie.
RÉMI OUELLET, propriétaire,
Auto Élégance select
- Les clients réservent leur
parce qu'ils ont peur d'arriver
puis qu'il soit déjà vendu,puis.
- L'inventaire de ce
s. Il a une trentaine
de véhicules d'occasion
à vendre, alors q
de la place pour 150.
C'est une conséquence directe
de la pandémie alors que
de nombreux constructeurs
ont dû freiner brusquement
leur production. Ajoutez à cela
avez la tempête parfaite
pour retarder la livraison
de véhicules neufs.
Les consommateurs se tournen
donc vers les voitures
de seconde main.
- On a des gens aussi
oAIce oAIce oAIce oAIce oAIce os
attendent un véhicule neuf
électrique ou autre, fait qu'ils
nous achètent un véhicule
pour le six mois ou un ane à par
pour avoir leur véhicule neuf.
- C'est au Québec que
l'augmentation du prix
d'un véhicule d'occasion est
comparativement à l'an dernier.
Prix moyen de 35 137 $,
selon AutoHebdo.
on a passé la côte, hein.
On est sur le plateau, et ça va
redescendre nécessairement parce
que c'es
c'est l'offre et la demande.
- Le Québec est la province dont
l'inventaire de véhicules ne
a le moins augmenté au pays
l'an dernier. À moins
patientez avant de vous acheter
une voiture, dit CAA, et pour
ceux qui louent le
Expert automobile de CAA Québece
de la valeur résiduelle garantie
qui est inscrite au bail,
qui est
on le rachète, on résiste
à la tentation de faire un
d'argent, et on le conserve.
- Ici Jérôme Bergeron,
Radio-Canada, Mo